- So do you believe in ghosts?
- Yeah, I wouldn't think
it'd be silly not to,
I believe in, you know
- Whatever could happen, I don't know --
- Yeah, I think that there is
spirits that get locked here
in tumultuous situations
and they get kinda stuck in
this Earth a little bit, so.
- I'm kind of like, on the,
I've never seen anything
like that but I'm like just
because I've never seen it
doesn't mean that it's not real,
so yeah, I'm kinda open
to it but I just don't
I'm not so open, I don't
want it ever to come to me --
- Yeah, I was about to
say don't be too open!
- I think they know!
- 'cause yeah, they
might be like ding dong!
- She'll go nuts!
- Hiya, how ya doing Kelly? (laughing)
- Yeah, that would, oh my god, I'd die!
(audience laughing)
I'd die. I just lost my breath
thinking about it, okay!
- You're actually freaking out!
- Like, I'm freaking out,
I don't like to be scared
or anything, I don't go to haunted houses,
I don't do any of it.
- Really?!
- No! Not at all!
- You don't like a...
- I love a haunted house!
- Nope! You can go with
your other friends.
- Really?
- Yup, yup!
- With my other friends,
- With your friends 'cause
- I'll go to a bar with you
- I used to put on a screen mask
and pop out
- Nope!
under mom's bed and stuff.
- And be like (growls scarily)!
- We probably can't be friends.
(laughing)
I don't do scary. Chloe...
- It was a creepy...
- Did you go all out for Halloween?
I do love Halloween I love dressing up,
not in scary things.
- I love Halloween!
- Really?
- No!
- Do you do more of the fun,
the fun Halloween things?
- I am like the one that,
you know all of my friends
I feel like all my friends
are going to be like
not all of them but a
lot of them would be like
it was their chance to look slutty
so it would be like a slutty
nurse, or a slutty fire fighter
- There's always a mouse!
- I'm a mouse or I'm a kitty! In a onesie!
And I was like, I was the friend,
like the comedian of the group,
I'd be like the one with,
like, a giant cow costume
with udders and like --
- Oh! Or, like, the
cowboy riding the horse
- Totally!
- And it's a blow up one.
- Anything for a laugh!